this is Peter Brown standing in for
freelance writer Cassidy Mosier for her
review of Ratchet and Clank for
PlayStation 4 the new Ratchet and Clank
is proof that there's still a lot of
mileage left in the 3d platformer genre
it's less of a reboot and more of a
return to form revitalizing and updating
the franchise while simultaneously
keeping its use of inventive weapons
alien worlds and quirky attitude intact
resurrecting and older franchise can be
a gamble but here the payoff is
plentiful Ratchet and Clank is a
technically rejuvenated version of the
PlayStation 2 classic it returns to the
same alien universe taking both ratchet
and his robot friend Clank to multiple
planets during their adventure
true to the series history there's a
large arsenal of weapons to play with
many of which have multiple applications
in combat pixel Iser is a powerful
blaster converting enemies into their
8-bit forms causing them to burst into a
mess of colorful squares when defeated
the bomb glow returns as a helpful
grenade tossing weapon capable of
devastating large groups of enemies then
the groovey Tron kicks out a funky beat
and distracts enemies from attacking by
launching them into a dancing frenzy
each weapon is distinct and all of them
have robust upgrade trees to make them
all the more effective against many
different enemy types there's a generous
offering of gadgets as well including a
modification that turns Clank into a jet
pack and the trespasser device that
grants ratchet access to new areas
through a hacking minigame items are
arguably more important than the weapons
since a majority of each level is built
to utilize different combinations of
them in an effort to streamline this
process necessary items are
automatically equipped to ratchet by
interaction points in each level
allowing you to focus on building up
your weapon upgrades and tinkering with
guns that best suit your playstyle as a
bonus there are benefits to backtrack
into older levels and using newfound
items to gain access to previously
unavailable areas although it maintains
the same tight and restricted
environments of its predecessors there's
a great deal of verticality hidden
elements and side objectives in each
level to lend players more content to
dig through a levels objective flow
sticks to the traditional format of
visiting planets defeating enemies and
moving on to save another planet in
peril
while the objectives rarely change
however the way things are accomplished
do one level may be a dogfight in the
sky which ratchet has to take down enemy
warships another may be a smaller more
puzzle focused challenge for Clank to
resolve but not as prevalent as the
standard shooter platformer levels but
they do serve as a nice break up
challenge in-between Ratchet and Clank
is delightfully self-aware and the story
begins with an imprisoned captain Qwark
the egomaniac leader of the Galactic
Rangers with whom ratchet has a somewhat
colorful history
throughout the game quark narrates a
story while telling a fellow inmate
about how we first met ratchet
he's endearing for a narcissist buffoon
and his narration is central to ratchet
and clanks charm he sometimes unreliable
embellishing parts of the story to make
it seem more grandiose and heroic his
enemies vanquished ratchet thorns to
head his destination destiny other times
he comments on the players in-game
actions with ratchet making smaller
marks about ratchets lack of gadgets or
movement which is as entertaining as it
is helpful strength of each character is
important because the story itself is
probably Ratchet and Clank weakest point
it's a basic story about two hapless
misfits who set out to achieve a dream
and save the galaxy from catastrophe at
the hands of a greedy and mad antagonist
other than a rush to an awkward ending
there's nothing unforgivable about it it
just serves more as a vehicle for the
characters who outshine everything else
in the narrative you alright pal Ratchet
and Clank finest attribute is its
visuals nearly everything is absolutely
stunning from the environmental design
to the character animations each planet
visited in-game looks different from any
other with brilliant color and texture
popping on-screen characters distinct
designs are borrowed from aspects of
their personalities from the goofy soul
patch and sunglasses of skid Mick Marx
to the sickly pallor of the evil
chairman drek the animations are
beautiful lending characters and
elasticity in their movement making them
appear both cartoony and fluid this
along with detailed particle effects and
vibrant environments make the game
visually spectacular Ratchet & Clank is
every bit as dynamic and fun as the 2002
original it's endearing and entertaining
a veritable power fantasy fueled by
rockets and carried by specialty gadgets
ring introducing a classic franchise to
a new generation is a difficult task but
Ratchet & Clank is a shining example of
how it can be done thanks for your help
no problem
see you in the next reboot
you